[Musica]
d
avete mai salvato la vita una persona
chi di voi sa farlo
c'era una stanza all'ultimo piano della
casa di mia nonna in un paese di
montagna non troppo distante da qui
c'erano stoffe di tanti colori e
materiali diversi strumenti di vario
tipo ed enormi fogli bianchi sui quali
prendevano vita modelli che partivano da
curve a me incomprensibili era al
laboratorio di mamma una sarta io da
bambina amavo andarci spesso per
osservare in silenzio come lei riuscisse
a dare vita alle sue creazioni dalla
carta alla stoffa misurando tagliando
cucendo provando e riprovando ripetendo
questi passi in maniera a volte non
lineare fino a quando il modello non
calzava perfettamente fisico e sulla
corporatura della persona per la quale
questo era stato creato
ecco io oggi posso dire di fare lo
stesso solo che al posto della stoffa
uso la matematica il mio ago al mio
figlio sono un computer e i modelli di
costruisco sui dati che per quanto
grezzi e imperfetti sono ricchi di
informazione su che cosa vi starete
chiedendo
su quelli che sono gli attori delle
epidemie
ovvero un virus le persone
alle volte un insetto come ad esempio le
zanzare e l'ambiente in cui questi
interagiscono tra di loro per lavoro e
per passione studio le epidemie usando
modelli matematici e statistici che mi
permettono di rispondere a domande del
tipo con che velocità si sta diffondendo
il virus quanti infatti può causare
questa epidemia e che impatto potrebbe
avere un vaccino e talvolta i modelli mi
permettono di prevedere ovvero
anticipare quello che potrebbe succedere
in futuro ne avreste creduto se a metà
gennaio vi avessi detto che un nuovo
coronavirus di origine animale avrebbe
infettato più di 22 milioni di persone
avrebbe fatto quasi 800 mila morti
sono sicura che nei mesi scorsi vi
sarete chiesti almeno una volta
quando finisce questa emergenza quando
torneremo alla normalità alla nostra
vita che vivevamo fino allo scorso
gennaio
e se vivete in italia o come mai in gran
bretagna due paesi colpiti molto
duramente dal covi 19 o in altri paesi
che sono riusciti a piegare la curva
epidemica
probabilmente vi sarete anche chiedendo
il peggio lo abbiamo alle spalle o ci
sarà una seconda ondata questo che ho in
mano è un chicco di riso
immaginiamo che sia una persona infetta
ogni persona infetta ne conta già al 33
il numero di infetti cresce di
generazione in generazione seguendo una
legge esponenziale se contiamo il numero
di infetti in dieci generazioni
vediamo che questo numero sale da 139 27
81 e così via
nel giro delle prime cinque generazioni
passiamo da 1 a 243 243 grani ci stanno
comodamente in una mano e se ciascuno di
questi grandi fosse un infetto
riempiremo un aeroplano nel giro delle
seconde cinque generazioni
quindi nello stesso arco temporale nel
quale siamo passati da 1 a 243 passiamo
da 243 a più di 59.000 che sono tanti
così
ovvero ove avremo un numero di infetti
tanto grande da riempire uno stadio
quando no un nuovo virus emerge il
numero di casi cresce sempre in maniera
esponenziale
ovvero all'inizio molto lentamente e ad
un certo punto esplode una curva
epidemica più o meno il profilo di una
montagna la salita che cresce all'inizio
dolcemente poi si fa sempre più dura
ad un certo punto dobbiamo addirittura
arrampicare usando le mani ma prima di
arrivare in vetta la salita rallenta la
crescita esponenziale non dura per
sempre ma quando un'epidemia fa il suo
corso
la discesa comincia solo quando si è
raggiunta la famosa immunità di gregge
questo è uno di quei risultati della
matematica dell'epidemia dai quali non
si scappa
e fino a quando non avremo raggiunto
questa famosa in unità di gregge o con
l'infezione naturale o in un futuro
speriamo non troppo lontano aiutati da
un vaccino
l'emergenza non sarà finita l epidemia
può riprendere più contagioso e un virus
più grande è la porzione di popolazione
che deve sviluppare questa immunità
prima che l'emergenza finisca e per il
copy 19 si tratta circa del 60 70 per
cento della popolazione
il problema è che oltre a essere molto
contagioso questo virus causa anche una
malattia molto grave e dalle tale e
quindi si è dovuto intervenire e ad oggi
si stima che nemmeno nelle parti più
colpite d'italia si è stata raggiunta
questa immunità di grecia in realtà se
n'è ancora molto lontani e quindi quasi
paradossalmente siamo lontani dalla fine
dell'emergenza
anche se siamo riusciti a frenare o a
fermare l'epidemia perché di fatto il
virus non è sparito con l'ancora e lo fa
con la stessa forza di sempre avremo
dunque una seconda ondata
la risposta è dipende perché i modelli
non sono una palla di cristallo
i modelli sono uno strumento che usando
le parole di robert gates che è un che
al fondatore della matematica
dell'epidemia impone chiarezza e
precisione rendendo possibile paragonare
in maniera
le conseguenze di semplici ipotesi con i
fatti
e i modelli permettono di esplorare
scenari che sono costruiti sulla base
delle informazioni che abbiamo
disponibili nel momento in cui facciamo
l'analisi e sulla base di ipotesi è una
delle ipotesi più difficili da impostare
da prevedere al comportamento umano che
varia nel tempo e nello spazio sulla
base di moltissimi fattori tra i quali
le informazioni che possono essere
scientifiche o meno le regole sociali le
nostre abitudini e la politica
ci siamo mai chiesti come evitare un
singolo contagio può cambiare la
traiettoria di un'epidemia
torniamo per un secondo all'esempio
della crescita esponenziale ai nostri
chicchi di riso spezzare un singolo
anello nella catena di trasmissione alla
prima generazione può ridurre il numero
dei contatti per 30 per cento ovvero un
singolo contagio evitato può risparmiare
fino a 20 mila infezioni e salvare circa
200 vite o anche di più perché in media
ciascun inferto ne conta gli altri tre
ma sappiamo bene che la media nasconde
spesso di vari e infatti i dati ci
dicono che un numero relativamente
piccolo di eventi cosa la maggior parte
delle opzioni questi eventi che si
conoscono come fenomeni di super
diffusione avvengono i luoghi di
aggregazione più frequentemente al
chiuso dove non si rispettano regole
semplici e di base come stare a casa ed
isolarsi se si è malati e si hanno
sintomi mantenere le distanze indossare
correttamente una mascherina e lavarsi
spesso le mani ed è proprio qui che le
scelte le azioni individuali vengono ad
amplificarsi nel bene e nel male e hanno
il potere il potenziale di andare a
cambiare la traiettoria di un'epidemia
i modelli ci dicono che l'emergenza
coronavirus non è finita
allo stesso tempo modelli e l'evidenza
dei fatti ci dicono che l'epidemia può
essere soppressa e una seconda ondata è
vietata
ma se questo scenario
si avvererà dipende fondamentalmente da
noi
stephen fry che è un famoso attore e
scrittore britannico disse un paio di
anni fa
futuro incerto anche se dista solo un
giorno e il destino del mondo sarà
determinata dalla strada che ciascuno di
noi sceglie di percorrere oggi non è il
virus che si diffonde sono le persone
stiamo noi che diffondiamo il virus è in
situazioni di emergenza
l'unica cosa che possiamo fare è
scegliere come reagire e come agire
consapevoli che ciascuno di noi ha un
ruolo fondamentale e può davvero fare la
differenza
grazie
[Musica]